well the historical figure that I find
most inspiring is as a Muslim the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
and I think that the reason for that is
because he he brought to the world a
message that could resonate with the
young and the old at the same time the
rich and the poor at the same time women
and men at the same time he brought a
message that was so resilient and so
flexible that it it could thrive in
societies as different as China and
Nigeria and I think that one of the
biggest challenges today is to
rediscover that vitality and not allow
Islam to become ossified as a rigid
force in very basic terms he brought a
message that said that nothing was
worthy of worship except God and and
what that means the implications of that
simple message was that all humans had
were therefore equal if no one could be
worshipped except God then no one was
superior to anyone else in fact
explicitly said that all human beings
were as equal as teeth on a comb so the
way I understand that it was a message
of human liberation of a liberation from
slavery from one human to another and
instead for all humans to serve God
alone